good afternoon and welcome to designing
dope distributed systems for outer space
with High Fidelity simulation uh my name
is Toby Bell I'm a PhD student in the
space rendevu laboratory at Stanford
University advised by Professor Simone
Deo uh I want to say much thanks to
strange Loop for inviting me to speak
this year I'm really honored to be here
especially for the last year of it uh
and thank you to all of you for uh
giving me your time and attention this
afternoon so dope distributed systems
for outer space with High Fidelity
simulation um the in this presentation
the primary thing that I want to share
is a case study in advanced software
testing techniques in three parts in the
first part I'm going to talk about uh a
spacecraft flight Control software
package for an upcoming space mission
called visor um that uh my team and I
have been working on for the last year
and a half or so it's dope uh it's a
pretty cool piece of software if I say
so myself uh I'm not biased but it's an
unprecedented mission in many ways and
certainly presents a lot of challenges
and
opportunities I'm going to talk about a
way we've used a particular testing
technique extensively in developing this
software um and in my opinion this has
been indispensable in us being able to
create the software the way we have I
think we've been able to move quicker
test more thoroughly and ultimately
create more capable software with than
we could have
otherwise um and this is not just for
space I hope that these techniques might
be useful to some of you um it can be
applied really to a wine range of
systems so that's what I'll be talking
about
today first up
visors so visors is a satellite uh space
mission launching ing next year in
October 24 October
2024 um it will be the first distributed
Space Telescope consisting of two 6u
Cube SATs flying in close formation in
low earth orbit uh for reference a sixu
cubat is about maybe this big it's like
20 cm by 30 cm you could kind of hold it
in your
hand the science objective of this
mission is to image the solar Corona in
the extreme ultraviolet Spectrum with
higher res resolution than has ever been
done before and we're aiming to do that
on two very lowcost 6 U Cube
sets uh it's a very ambitious Mission
given its low cost it ends up Towing the
line between science Mission and
experimental technology demonstration
Mission so it's very
exciting it's a multi-institution
collaboration between I think 10
universities NASA GED space flight
center a company called Blue Canyon
Technologies um it was funded by the
national Science Foundation I believe
originally in 2018 2019 uh with an
original Grant amount of $4.6
million um distributed Space Telescope
like any telescope or like many
telescopes we consist of an optical
instrument and a detector but in our
case uh to achieve the unprecedented
resolution that we're going for the
focal length of this telescope is 40 m
that means we want 40 MERS between our
Optics and our detector that's probably
a little longer than the length of this
room so uh because we do not have the
budget nor the launch vehicle to launch
uh spacecraft like that the approach
we're taking here is to put the detector
and the Optics on two separate
spacecraft these spacecraft will align
themselves with the intended observation
Direction it's very
sci-fi uh and this has never been done
before we'll end up Hing pretty tight
tolerances on their alignment so
laterally we have a tolerance of 1.8 cm
for the alignment of the two spacecraft
and along the line of sight we have a
tolerance of 1.5 cm and we'll be holding
this alignment for an exposure time of
seconds in terms of the relative
geometry of the two spacecraft we get an
observation attempt once each time we
come around the earth so when we're in
science mode doing observations uh we'll
get this opportunity about every 90
minutes
uh highle concept of operations for the
mission uh we broadly divide the mission
into two modes standby mode which uh
uses a slightly further separation of
200 MERS for increased safety and only
enter science mode via a transfer
maneuver for short durations to perform
a limited number of observation attempts
before transferring back to
standby to give a visualization of this
concept of operations I have a little
demo that I can run and my terminal is
gone okay I found
it can I type up there am
I okay I'll just have to look at the um
the presentation here oh and it opened
on this
screen one moment let me just switch
switch to
mirroring no that's not what I wanted to
do
BR
okay great okay so here's the Earth um
here are our two
spacecraft uh so let me give a a
reference here
so um we'll be at a altitude of about 5
50 km um we have two spacecraft depicted
here this one is they're just white dots
sorry I only had so much time uh this
one is the detector this one is the
optic spacecraft uh the reference frame
that we're using for this visualization
with this three-coordinate access is
some astrodynamics for you is called the
rtn frame we use it often in spacecraft
relative motion and it's defined locally
depending on where you are in your orbit
so the r Direction which is red here
always points up radially away from the
Earth the T Direction in green points
generally the direction that you're
moving in the orbit and the N or normal
direction is sort of like your angular
moment momentum Vector that's normal to
your
orbit um in this visualization we've got
a couple reference uh ovals here which
are not perfectly positioned again I
only had so much time but the green
orbit roughly represents that 200 meter
standby orbit the red orbit is that 40 m
science orbit and we have an animation
showing the uh transfer trajectory
between them
the yellow Vector here which we'll be
moving is our intended observation
Direction which is essentially just
pointing towards the Sun at all times
this will be moving around as the
animation plays since the orientation of
the rtn frame is changing but it's the
same direction in inertial space so the
transfer looks like
this and our software uh plans a
sequence of Maneuvers shown here as
yellow points in the orbit that are
designed to take us from the standby
trajectory to the science trajectory and
back and this transfer sequence takes
maybe 10 orbits or so which might be the
better of heart of a day um but it will
gradually take us from one to the other
while preserving desirable safety
properties about the orbits so that we
don't have any risk of collisions I'll
fast forward a little bit to when we're
in science mode and you can see that
once we're there the science trajectory
that we're in is constantly tuned by
Maneuvers that are planned autonomously
on board the spacecraft the loop needs
to be closed tighter than we could
achieve using ground stations so this
all has to be done on board and we
achieve this alignment with the intended
observation Vector once per orbit so as
that yellow Vector is swinging around
that's pointing towards the sun you can
see we just line up and kiss it once per
orbit and each time we do that we do an
observation attempt when we're done with
all of those we start a transfer back to
standby mode uh which is also done
autonomously in the worst case or by
ground command if we want to do it
sooner so that hopefully gives a sense
of what these two spacecraft will have
to be doing mostly autonomously um again
it's very sci-fi I think this is the
coolest stuff so that's
that and maybe I can go back can I stop
mirroring okay they're all
wrong where's my
cursor am I on the display button
you know I'll just mirror it'll be
simpler our piece that my team at the
space rev laboratory is creating is the
GNC or guidance navigation and control
subsystem for the mission this is a
stateful software component that is
responsible for doing all of the motion
estimation and control for both
spacecraft we run a mission mode State
machine that runs on both spacecraft in
sync to maintain that highle concept of
operations of the mode switching we are
responsible for maintaining safety of
the formation by using passive and
active collision avoidance and
ultimately we need to achieve that
required centimeter level observation
alignment uh more generally my lab the
space rendevu lab uh focuses on Advanced
multi-satellite systems to enable
precise navigation and control often
with the end goal of Novel science
applications environment
characterization and uh performing
rigorous validation and testing of these
algorithms along the way so if you're
interested in in more of our work you
can check us out at slab. stanford.edu
to give a bit of a context of how our
piece fits in with the rest of the
system we have two instances of the
guidance navigation control Library
running on both
spacecraft that's wrapped in another
piece of software called the hosted
software app this is developed by a team
students at Georgia Tech that runs on
top of Linux on top of a flight computer
Pro provided by the bus from Blue Canyon
Technologies our commercial
partner that's connected to a bunch of
Hardware mostly sensors and actuators to
tell us where we are allow us to control
where we're going those are connected to
reality we also have a cross link for
doing networking between our two
spacecraft um it's a lossy cross link
and it's also a research component this
is a a new piece of Hardware that's not
flown before this uh we have two GPS
receivers on both spacecraft which are
connected to up to one of the 31 active
GPS satellites that are up
there um GPS this is incidentally is how
we're achieving the uh very high precise
High Precision navigation um we will be
doing the first to our knowledge first
ever use of realtime differential GPS
with integer ambiguity resolution in
space um which is how we can get
cim accurate relative State estimates
from GPS which normally is only accurate
to like meters in the best
case we also have ground
radios so I want to give a bit of a
sense of the actual API to the GNC
system because it's relevant to the rest
of my talk so at a high level this is I
copied this from the header file that we
delivered to Georgia Tech um we uh have
just a statically allocated or I mean
they can allocate it however they want
but we just have a struct that's here's
our working memory for GNC please put
this somewhere we give them a function
to initialize it they can provide some
callbacks function pointers for us to
get outputs to them and then we have a
bunch of functions that they can call to
give us various kinds of information at
any time um I'll go through these
briefly they give you a sense of the
kinds of computations we're doing we
take configuration data time at tone
this comes from our spacecraft bus and
contains attitude information our
orientation and general system Health
keeping um GPS messages these come
straight from receiver Hardware uh laser
ranges cross link messages from the
opposite GNC instance on the other
spacecraft ground messages Telemetry
from the propulsion system which we use
to react to tune our maneuver planning
um the current Target formation level
Target that's that high level uh Mission
concept of operations and a tick which
is basically a a request to do some work
at a later time that we might have asked
for in the
past on the output side they provide a
bunch of function pointers to us uh so
that we can output Maneuvers
instantaneously whenever we want one
performed we can call that as a call
back and they'll send it to the
hardware power States for various
Hardware our own Telemetry this is just
recorded for down link cross link
messages to send to the opposite
spacecraft ticks those requests to do
work at a later time we can output those
uh sing before and after an observation
the current mode for triggering various
configurations on the spacecraft uh sort
of fault detection flag for whether we
think something has gone wrong in GNC
and at a system level they should take a
take a reaction um and some safety
violation we also have a call back for
us to just request the the current time
the current system time we just use this
for internal benchmarking of
algorithms a sense of our code we our
flight code is uh just a bunch of C++ we
have three main libraries lib slab lib
digital and lib visors slab and digital
are shared with other flight projects in
my lab visor is just dedicated to this
Mission um you can you can see it's
pretty tiny we go to pretty Great
Lengths to keep the amount of code that
we have small um this is not because our
code is simple but I think we are pretty
intentional about trying to avoid
duplication and any given thing that we
want to do uh we try to do it as
absolutely simply as we can because
there's enough complexity to juggle
already we have a few third party
dependencies EOS is a second order cone
program solving library for doing
numerical optimization this is used for
one of our maneuver planning algorithms
uh and sofa standards of fundamental
astronomy is a library that contains a
bunch of coordinate frame definitions
and other sort of uh astrodynamics
routines those are a bunch of lines of
code but we only use like one or two
functions from them uh and then we have
a um just a library of our support code
our testing code which I'll be talking
about in the rest of this
presentation we have a very small team
it's four of us myself and three other
students as well as our adviser so our
time is limited uh also so none of us
are really working on this full-time
we're all students trying to work on
publishing and our own research so um
really anything we can do to move faster
is is a great
win I think for the sake of time I won't
talk through these in detail but there
are a lot of challenges that we face in
designing this software here are some of
them uh take a look um if you want you
can ask questions about them later but
uh I'll skip elaborating on them for
now
so that's an overview of visors I now
want to talk about the way that we used
simulation testing extensively
throughout the development of this uh
and what that looked like for
us
[Applause]
so as far as software testing goes
software environments go um spacecraft
software is probably one of the most
extreme
disconnects you can find between
development and
production if we consider the number of
factors and extent of factors that
contribute to what exactly is the
environment that software is running in
on a spacecraft there's so many things
coming into the spacecraft as inputs
that software in theory should expect to
be there and might rely on sensor
measurements networking conditions
connectivity with ground stations and
other spacecraft Telemetry from hardware
systems um and as well as often somewhat
obscure processors and operating systems
for space grade Hardware that if you're
developing on a desktop computer and you
want to compile and run and make some
changes uh you're probably not going to
have all of these things looking the
same way as they would if you were
circling around the planet every hour
and a half on the other hand the
responsibilities of spacecraft software
are tend to to be pretty Mission
critical or can be Mission critical they
can affect the the lifek keeping of the
spacecraft your ability to even maintain
contact with it in the worst case um and
if you end up bricking a spacecraft
there's no reset button you can press um
unless you design one in which you
should do but um for the most part you
know I'm just saying you want your
software to work the first time if you
can
um it should come as no surprise then
that simulation is used extensively in
Aerospace also used in automotive really
any any field where you're writing
software that should be op out operating
in some environment that has these
unique
characteristics so how does that
normally look like in space software
usually what you do is you take your
system you isolate the pieces that are
your software your system under test and
you say we're going to replace
everything else with the simulation and
run our software based on inputs from
that
simulation that simulation very
simplified boiled down ends up taking
the form of just repeatedly stepping
time forward and writing a model for
what it looks like for the state of
those things to step forward this is not
your software this is everything that
you're replacing everything else in the
system that is not your software you
want to basically write software that
mimics the behavior of all of that
stuff in visors we ended up using a
simulation testing framework that
despite simulation being ubiquitous in
space applications you'd be very
hardpressed to find a space spacecraft
software that was not using simulation
testing extensively I think there are
three unique aspects to what we ended up
implementing for our testing framework
um those are I would say first extreme
High Fidelity I'll talk about what I
mean by that in a
minute it's very deterministic we prize
this very much um and it's much faster
than real
time uh our simulation basically looks
the same as the diagram I just showed
here's roughly what it looks like for us
to compile it we take our flight code in
libg nc.a uh a bunch of testing code in
lib support. and we just compile them
together and we get a single executable
out which we can run um I will show a
demo of running
that and while that's running I'll talk
a little bit about what's going on so
this is a simulation case that we run
all the time in slab uh it takes about 1
minute to run and it ends up running
that full trajectory that you saw
earlier so the visualization that I
generated earlier was produced directly
from a log of output of this simulation
this simulation is running the full
software GNC software on both spacecraft
as well as the ground software that
we're writing for our part in slab and
doing so in a completely deterministic
much faster than real-time way despite
running the actual full as compiled
flight software um the benefits that we
get from this running everything in a
single process and also in this case in
a single thread is we have very easy
debug ability we can run the entire
system litter assertions everywhere and
if ever anything breaks we can see
exactly where we can step through calls
between different like literal computers
running different pieces of software uh
within the simulation um and we also
kind of
interestingly get system level profiling
so you could just run a CPU profiler on
this software and look at what are the
most CPU intensive parts of your entire
system regardless of where they might be
running if you actually deployed this on
different pieces of Hardware so because
we run on limited hardware for
spacecraft that has also been
indispensable uh for making sure that
our algorithms run in the times we need
them to on our limited space
Hardware so we run that all the time
this was about 48 hours worth of
simulation of exactly what our our
software would be running over those 48
hours in theory in theory
um within about a
minute so I'll talk a little bit more
about each of these three aspects what I
mean by it and how we achieved it first
High Fidelity what does this mean for us
there's two key components of our
simulation being high fidelity that I
think are very important the first is
testing our real bonafed flight Software
System under test I put this on here
because in the space industry in my
experience other places I've worked in
the space industry often uh you have
simulation testing but it's applied to a
somewhat simplified model of the
software maybe it's a prototype written
in a different programming language like
python or mat laab uh or it's using
something like matlb simulink and then
counting on uh automatic code generation
to turn that into C code or something
like that um that can work for simple
systems but for something at the level
of complexity of visors where we're very
concerned with making sure we're sque
squeezing every like time interval out
that we can of our software and not
wasting any time using outdated
information we want to build our real
software as it will be compiled in
Flight in C++ and testing that directly
the other one is model as many sources
of noise in your simulation as you can
there are many of these in our
simulation you can imagine there's a lot
of physical ones sources of uncertainty
in the physical effects and forces on
our spacecraft we don't always know
exactly how dense the atmosphere is at
each point in the orbit we don't know
how bright the sun will be at any given
time which affects the amount of
swelling of the atmosphere and also just
uh force from the momentum's B the
momentum of photons bouncing off our
spacecraft um there's also the
non-spherical gravity of the earth so we
model as many of these physical effects
as we can I'm going to talk about one in
more detail because I think it'd be most
interesting to most of this audience
which is for the network aspect of our
cross link um we use our cross link
directly we have a a datagram model for
this it's lossy uh so we want to
simulate this in our in our
simulation and we do this by in our
simulation code having a function that
represents the act of sending something
across the cross link and we can Define
Some Noise parameters for it so we can
define a minimum 3 Sigma and maximum 3
Sigma bound on how long it should take
for something to be received over this
um and we can also have a drop rate if
we want we can make these numbers
however bad we want if we want to stress
test things and in this implementation
we currently use a log normal
distribution which is probably not the
most physically accurate model of
network latency we have not we actually
don't have a characterization of how our
particular cross link radio which is
untested Hardware in space will farare
at the 400 meters 200 meters so we are
pulling numbers out of our ass but we
can pick conservative numbers if we want
to and once we calculate how long we
want it to take and if we want to
actually have this be received we can
just schedule an event in our simulation
to say okay at this time please run the
code that whoever asked me to
representing the receipt of this
message when we use this uh we can use
this from our simulation for the hosted
software app that part that Georgia Tech
is running which wraps the GNC library
and in our callback this gets passed to
those callbacks as a function pointer to
the GNC library that represents sending
a cross link message we can just get a
reference to our peer because we're in
simulation so we can access whatever we
want and just say send a cross link this
will model that randomized delay and
drop percentage and at the other side we
at the other side we'll just call the
GNC in Cross link message input from our
API
directly that's a a bit of a look at
some of the ways we model noise sources
in our
simulation determinism this is very
important it's what enables us to really
get all the benefits of debugging and
traceability and worst case print
statement debugging because if you run a
simulation for a month of your mission
and something goes wrong on day 20 you
can just add some instrumentation and
run it again and know that you're going
to hit the exact same problem when you
run it again on day
20 two ingredients to it make your
system under test
deterministic and make the simulation
deterministic um I say these
intentionally to say it's obvious but it
does take work and intention to do that
in our case for making our system
deterministic this was something there's
no magic here there's no secret sauce or
like enforcement for it especially
because we're in C++ um you could
certainly use language tools to enforce
determinism um by using a more maybe of
more pure functional language but in our
case we want the flexibility and the
control of C++ and also the broad
compiler support for a wide range of
targets because of the diversity of
space Hardware um
so on that note with C++ you can
intentionally violate determinism a
little bit if you want so you might
notice we don't provide a memory
allocation call back here we do entirely
rrap calls to Malik and we do use
Dynamic allocation technically that
makes our system non-deterministic but
we're accepting that and we also have
tight uh memory budget requirements
anyway which we're monitoring for our
mission so for all intents and purposes
Malik will always work for us
the rest of our calls however are
designed to give GNC everything that
they need and everything that it needs
in order to be able to compute the same
result every time um in particular call
out a few things we make all of our
networking and all of our scheduling
very explicit so for example our cross
link message and ground messages we
could internally I mean like I said
we're running on Linux we could open
sockets internally inside our software
we choose not to because we want to make
our our software's Behavior a pure
function of what we pass to these
function these input calls we don't have
to do that but it's desirable to it
allows us to have this complete
determinism and ease of testing same
thing with tick we basically use this to
replace calls to the operating system
scheduler so instead of where we might
put a sleep call saying I want to
suspend my thread please call me back uh
in 5 seconds to the operating system
directly we create this as an output
from GNC and leave it up to the client
to Define what that means
in the case of the simulation side
determinism use a seated random number
generator uh we use the C++ built-in
mercen one uh you can do this in any
environment presumably um again no magic
sauce just be disciplined about it and
make sure that you don't end up uh using
a non-seed call or introducing some
other source if you do you'll notice it
track it down before it gets too bad and
eliminate
it
so lastly the faster than realtime
aspect um we do this using event driven
simulation and built on top of a broadly
event driven system so we created GNC
from day one to be defined by
asynchronously arriving inputs the uh
hosted software app that Georgia Tech
creates is free to call us with sensor
measurements received messages at any
time that it want we describe that in
our API to them we would just like them
to call us as soon as they have any
information really so we don't want to
impose any restrictions of like you must
call us at this rate um if they do that
and we perform a little bit of work in
response to all of those we have a lot
of empty time in between when we just
aren't receiving uh like no nothing has
come in on the network or a given sensor
has not produced any measurements so we
can just get rid of all that time in
simulation and Skip from one interesting
thing to the next and we'll still get
the same
result we do this by implementing a very
simple event Loop in our simulation so
so in our top level Sim object uh we
have uh just a priority cue of events I
think whatever we have a priority que of
events uh and we have that schedule call
which you saw earlier when I implemented
the cross link delay um where we can
just take some callable object in C++
and we create a timestamped event object
with it throw it in the priority queue
it will be sorted by the time that it
should Ur occur and in our run Loop this
is the top level run Loop of the
simulation
uh we just repeatedly DQ the next event
because we want to run a physical
simulation as well we compute the amount
of time to the next event and run a step
function to say please propagate the
true dynamics of all our analog stuff by
that amount um if you're just doing
software simulation you might not need
that analog side and it could just be a
plain event Loop like you know like what
powers JavaScript or something where
you're just running a sequence of
functions using using this technique to
skip all of the empty time in our
simulation we can run a 30 orbit
simulation in 1 minute which is about a
2,880 time speed up um this depends on
your Hardware but this is just on my
computer so this is also like I said
running completely single threaded so
there's no reason we have to run the
simulation single threaded it's nice for
debuggability um and for Simplicity
we've kept it that way but if you were
trying to simulate many simultaneous uh
hosts running a bunch of different
software 100 nodes of something you
could parallelize your simulation and
just make all those run on separate
cores because I mean they should work
that anyway because ultimately they're
going to be on different
computers so that's our faster than
realtime simulation between all three of
these um these were really I feel like
indispensable tool in allowing us to
move very quickly um and just make
changes and instantly see how they
impact our entire system in a very
controllable
way that's a look at simulation testing
as we used it for visors third and
finally I want to talk about some
takeaways that I have for applying these
techniques to other systems not
necessarily Space
Systems
I uh software testing for a second uh
I'm going to throw up
two we can dispute what exactly each of
these mean but uh let's just say think
I'll know it when I see it uh two
extremes of software testing
um and I'll just say unit testing is
that kind of thing that you do on
functions and little pieces of your
program and they run quick and they're
like a little easier to work with and
then endtoend testing is what you do
when you have those scripts that you
want to stand up a bunch of services and
then sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't but it's important to do uh so
between those my thesis would be that I
think unit testing tis a lot of boxes
much better than an0 testing with two
important exceptions which is that
usually it does not test the whole
system and there's a lot of details um
that the devil can be in uh when you're
testing the whole system so I would
propose that a simulation t a simulation
testing approach like what we have for
visors does a pretty good job of hitting
both of these
strengths there's nothing that prevents
us from applying our simulations to
smaller components and we actually do
that there are multiple smaller
subsystems within the GNC comp component
that we have our own simulation tests
for for example running the navigation
side independently of the control side
to just test our estimation or vice
versa um so you can really drill down as
much as you want if you want to test a
piece in isolation but we have
determinism we have uh encouraging good
code structure by making these
interfaces explicit um we have debug
ability easy to run them automated they
run very quickly and we can test for the
most part the entirety of our systems
there are two related past strange Loop
talks that are very like relevant to
this kind of approach of testing
software that I want to mention um the
first is a strange Loop 2014 talk uh I
was talking about it uh to some people
earlier today it's a great talk uh it
touches on a lot of these same points
that I've mentioned um that's from
Foundation DB uh and referring to a C++
transpiler they've written called flow
that they use to take imperative looking
code in C++ turn it to a turn it into
asynchronous code and run it in a very
similar kind of event-driven
um artificial simulation environment
where they can completely model all of
the network behavior and dis access for
their database uh I want to draw a few
contrasts to that where I I think that
there's a lot of great stuff in that
talk but I think something it misses is
that I don't think you need a new
language I don't think you need a transp
or a big framework to do this kind of
technique um you can get away with being
intentional about the interfaces in your
application and using pretty lightweight
uh event Loop implementations things
like that and modeling your domain
however is best for you so uh I think
that there are probably many teams that
maybe feel like simulation testing would
require adopting a big framework when in
reality it might
not and the other one is also from
strange Loop 2014 and it's just called
simulation testing by Michael niggard um
and in that talk uh he talks about again
very similar to the kinds of things I'm
talking about here uh his talk is in is
in closure and he mentions a few
libraries that they use to do this kind
of dynamic input generation model a
simulation of uh traffic to a service
and test the entire flow of their system
in response to that traffic um again
something that I think that is maybe
missed in that talk is that that you can
do this I think you can do this in any
language you can do it in a systems
language um my take away from that talk
simulation simulation testing is it
feels a little bit like the the
functional aspect of closure is very
important for enabling the kind of
testing they do and again I would
contest that and say it again just
depends on you being intentional about
making explicit all of the input and
output from your system you can always
make a pure functional system out of a
language like C++ um the of C++ is that
you can take little shortcuts here and
there like I said we we decided to skip
Malik Malik is fine with
us so the biggest single piece of advice
takeaway that I would give from my
experience implementing this in visors
is pay extreme attention to the
boundaries of your system what do I mean
by that if our software is our GNC
libraries and a little bit of ground
software the most important thing in how
well we can test our software using
simulator
is the design of our apis for these if
we look again at the API for GNC I think
there are three particular things that
are somewhat unusual about this API
design um those are the absence of uh
networking scheduling and like file IO
that we make explicit here that
sometimes uh in I could imagine other
apis they would just sort of be
invisible they'll happen for you we'll
just do them with the operating system
which seems convenient but it has
drawbacks so to call these out in the
case of scheduling we have this in tick
and out tick function what is this uh we
call out tick as a call back from GNC
whenever we want to do some work at a
later time and we just Define it's part
of the API it's part of the interface
that whoever implements this whoever our
client is whatever the user is they
better call us back at that time in the
future on the one hand this makes more
work for them on the other hand it makes
it very easy for us to test our full
software as built in a simulation
environment faster than real time this
ends up really being equivalent to what
you would normally doing be doing with
any other scheduling kind of interface
whether you're calling sleep and putting
something after it or calling a set
timeout in JavaScript and passing it
some code to run in both of those cases
you're calling some system saying I
would like to be called at a later time
please jump to this code it's a little
invisible in the Sleep call but you are
passing a pointer in your return address
uh and then the scheduler is just
jumping back to you at a later time to
give you that control again so all we've
done with our API though it looks a
little unusual is Make That
explicit um on the network side we have
our input cross link message and output
cross link message you already saw those
earlier that's very similarly often that
would be invisible in an API um
internally you might open a socket and
say please send this packet I'll ask the
operating system to tell me back that's
that's fine it makes your API convenient
but by talking directly to the operating
system you make it much harder for
yourself to test your software's
behavior and your software's behavior
alone it's almost like you're making the
entire operating system a part of your
software's
behavior and lastly file access we have
a few calls that are kind of equivalent
to US reading from a config file in
practice our configuration will be
stored in non-volatile storage on the
spacecraft we could have read that
ourselves but we didn't this makes it
very easy for us to test
deterministically
when we output Telemetry we have a call
back for it we don't write to a file
ourselves so by removing all of these
things from our system this is how we
achieve the desirable properties that
make them very easy to test
deterministically and
quickly and when we wrap them in a
simulation we can interface with all
those removed removed pieces and
basically mock whatever those Services
would have been so at the end of the day
I've said this a few times I don't think
there's anything super magical or
fundamental going on here this is just
follow all of the testing advice you've
ever heard
um but at the level of the whole system
as opposed to individual functions so
before I started on this project I had
not ever really seen this done super
concretely before I didn't really have a
good feel for what it meant to say you
know remove these dependencies at a
system level I'd seen lots of examples
of dependency injection mocking whatever
for functions classes
but it's not so obvious what it means to
do that for a whole network or a file
system or
AER now one might
say Let me let me gather my
thoughts Toby of course it's easier to
test now you've removed all of the
important stuff the networking the file
system access the hardware interfaces
you've removed all that from your system
but that stuff still has to exist
somewhere and now it's just going to
break outside of what you're
testing I I had to rehearse that a few
[Applause]
times uhoh
sorry from your
system but that stuff still has to exist
somewhere so now it will just break
outside of the what you're testing fals
um okay my response to this I I think
there's some truth to this but I think
it's not a complete criticism of this
technique for a few reasons the first is
uh we've done it so as part of our
testing in the space rendevu lab of our
software uh we've done some processor in
the loop testing where we take the GNC
component and run it on a Raspberry Pi
why because it's what we had lying
around and it's arm 32 which is much
closer to what the flight computer will
run than my my laptop um and we just put
a very small serialization uh library in
between the API on both sides and put a
executable around it that just opens a
socket and reads data over a TCP socket
and calls those functions in GNC and
wraps the callbacks from the outputs of
GNC and sends those back over the TCP
socket and uh this was for all intents
and purposes a very small piece of code
and also subjectively it was really not
a pain to write this code or to test it
um none of the flakiness in the system
came from anything that we wrote here we
wrote this and after maybe a few cycles
of debugging like okay I I got that
argument to that system call wrong uh it
it worked fine the behavior that all the
flakiness that we're testing had already
been debugged previously from running
our software in the loop tests with our
modeled noise and our cross link all of
the other unreliability sources that we
have in our simulation and once we got
this running on a separate processor it
ran perfectly fine so based on that
experience I would say that even if
you're taking that thin layer of
interfacing with an operating system and
moving it outside of your system I
actually don't think that's really where
the complexity is if you've defined your
interface in such a way that you can
Implement that simply on top of
operating system interfaces you'll
probably not have too hard a Time the
other reason is uh ultimately you can do
a little bit of end to end testing I
mean you can do a lot of endend testing
you can do as much as you want the point
of simulation testing is to be used as
maybe a a more common default something
can run quicker day-to-day I mean we
just use this in place of unit testing a
lot of the time because it it tests with
more coverage than we'd get from unit
testing and it is so fast for us to run
we can just test our whole system in a
minute yeah
okay so that's my biggest takeaway uh
is design your systems with interfaces
to remove the internal stuff that you
might be used to just reaching directly
for an operating system API for and make
it a very concrete part of your system
boundary and once you put that actually
running on production you can write a
thin little wrapper around it that
connects those two but in simulation you
going have a really easy route in to
make everything really deterministic and
fast
I think that's about what I just said so
I won't repeat all
that so those are a few of my takeaways
um in summary uh visors is a very
exciting Mission and a very complex
mission that I don't think we would have
been able to develop as well as we have
um and with the amount of confidence
that I feel in the software after seeing
it run and seeing it misbehave and crash
many times uh over unreliable network
connections and all that and having
debugged that but in a way where we can
run a simulation the exact same way over
and over and figure out exactly what is
going wrong when something goes wrong
and fixing that um these techniques are
not just applicable to space though
space makes broad use of simulation uh I
think it's something that could benefit
a lot of especially distributed systems
but any software and uh I think the key
thing for enabling that is intention
about making all of your input and
output explicit to say it for the
hundredth
time thank you very much that's my
[Applause]
talk